do you remember I don't want to say
celebrate but do you remember dates when
bad things happen like my wife remembers
the date that our mother passed away you
remember the date that you signed the
divorce papers you know you can remember
the date it's not like you celebrate it
but you do remember it you know I'm to
the point now I'm almost ready to
celebrate it Saturday will be September
the 22nd that is 30 years to the day
from when I filed bankruptcy it's been
30 years and all the wonderful things
that have happened because that happened
makes me almost want to celebrate it
that's sick but you know what I mean I
owned a whole bunch of real estate and
if that had just been successful I would
just be a guy that owned a bunch of real
estate and there's nothing wrong with
that that would have been a good life I
would have had fun and not like real
estate and I like dealing with the
uniqueness of each property is there's
nothing vanilla about the business it's
a new adventure every day I'm always
going to be a real estate guy in my soul
but if I hadn't failed that's what I'd
be I guess but we all failed only you
ever think about where you would be if
you didn't get knocked down I would have
just been a guy that owned some real
estate again there's nothing wrong with
that but I mean man what a wonderful
life I've had because it's not the path
you should take I'm not suggesting this
young people it's a better way to get to
your passion to get to God's calling on
your life than
I got and what's strange is 30 years I
know I'm getting old because I remember
the old stories more than I remember
yesterday I can feel when I'm talking to
you on the radio I can feel the
emotional pain of a 27 year old guy with
a brand-new baby and a toddler that's
scared out of his mind I can feel that
more real than I can feel the emotion I
felt yesterday about something and it
was 30 years ago I guess it just left a
mark doesn't it it's a wound and that
you know if you I cut my leg when I was
a kid and I've still got the scar on my
leg it wasn't like a bazillion stitches
I cut it really bad so that's place on
my leg for the rest of my life we'll be
sensitive you know I don't want to touch
it
it still hurts you know it's a scar it's
a wound and I guess that's what I've got
on my heart and I guess you guys too I
mean you get knocked down you get
knocked out of the saddle you get thrown
off the horse you get things don't turn
out like you think they're going to turn
out well duh we all kind of know that in
our intellect but when we're sitting in
the middle of it we can't help but whine
a little bit about it it's not supposed
to be this way you've said that I've
said that but I think you celebrate
something like what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger I think you celebrate
something like Romans 8:28 in the Bible
all things work together for good for
those that love the Lord and they're
called according to his purpose even the
painful horrible things that happen to
us or that we bring on ourselves with
our own stupidity because bankruptcy
didn't happen to me I caused it by
borrowing too much money I was just
straight-up stupid I mean I did stupid
it was
zeroes on the end man I can't claim
victim status I mean there were some
people in the banking world that did
some things that were illegal and they
did some things that were morally wrong
and certainly relationally and
spiritually wrong they just straight-up
lie steal cheat they mean they're just
nasty human beings but you know what I
set myself up for that because I walked
into the spiders light layer and then I
asked the spider not to eat me you know
come on that's just dumb so I mean III
exposed myself to these people not all
of them are crooks but I mean there were
some people that did some stuff that you
just it would have been pretty easy to
claim victim status I guess but victim
status doesn't get you there if you
don't go ok I get that but my part in
this is I'm so dumb I was in the room
you know my part in this was I mean
Bernie Madoff is a crook but yeah you
kind of just walked in there and gave
him a bunch of your money too and didn't
think about what you were doing so you
know yeah you're a victim no question he
was a crook I get all of that and I'm a
victim of me know greedy banks but then
they are me know greedy banks I'm gonna
use form for this day but but it's my
fault my fault
there's something about doing that that
changes the direction of your life
because it gives you the dignity of
making different choices if you assume
the position of a victim then you assume
you don't have any control over any of
the variables in your life and you're
stuck people like me all headed people
can't win well I'm bald so I'm just
screwed you know I mean what does that
mean you know my family's obesity runs
in my family
no nobody runs in your family that's the
problem you know you gotta think about
this you could take the victim thing
right and you can decide this people
like me people from my neighborhood
people of whatever millenials Baby
Boomers Xers week you know we people all
people there's ageism now it's just as I
mean it happens to everyone I know I had
things happen to everybody and everybody
gets a stupid card and some of us play
the whole deck you know so I'm gonna
celebrate today this weekend is the 30th
anniversary of the bankruptcy the day
that God loved me enough that changed
the direction of my life so that my life
would have a whole lot more meaning than
it was on track to have I was just gonna
become a collector of stuff now I'm a
collector of stories your stories you
when you changed your life yeah you over
there I collect your stories
it's a better collection than a
collection of stuff this is the Dave
Ramsey show